notre prochain invité connaît bien cette
réalité que la commission parlementaire
a entrepris d'étudier mais les stalles
lubie elle est elle-même une survivante
d'exploitation sexuelle alors qu'elle
était mineure aujourd'hui elle est
intervenant pour la sortie c'est un
organisme des deux victimes des réseaux
de prostitution madame dubé bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous ce soir
alors vous vous avis je pense 15 ans
quand vous êtes tombé dans les griffes
d'un proxénète et allez pas vous êtes
pas rendu compte dans les faits que vous
étiez prisonnière que vous étiez
contrôlée par lui comme bien des jeunes
femmes d'ailleurs ouais j'ai pas
réaliser vraiment que j'étais victime
jusqu'à temps que
j'avais 30 ans à peu près pas ce que ça
veut pas de voir qu'une victime qui pour
moi j'ai embarqué dans l'industrie du
sexe comme un choix je pensais c'était
mon choix mais j'étais tellement
vulnérable j'avais été dans la dpj dans
des familles d'accueil voyager
la plupart de mon enfance j'ai vécu des
abus sexuels en tout cas j'ai embarqué
dans la drogue
alors quand que j'ai rencontré des
hommes d'affaires qui était établi
qu'ils avaient déjà un réseau de
prostitution
ça m'a pris même pas un ordre de prendre
la décision de embarqué que d'avoir déjà
le chemin de monde devant moi et puis
c'est ça le monsieur de il était payé
par les bars pour un délit mineur
alors ils voyageaient dans la province
de québec
et pourquoi ça nous a pris du temps
c'est parce que dans le fond ça vous
donnais c'était un travail que vous
cherchez vous cherchez vous libérer de
votre famille peut-être certains
contextes en tout cas et vous aviez
revenus mais dans le fond vous étiez pas
libre du tout de faire ce que vous
voulez il avec votre argent mais moi moi
je l'étais quand j'étais à genoux et je
l'était c'est une différente réalité
aujourd'hui est que les proxénètes 66 à
lui augmenté comme monsieur la première
disait que maintenant c'est le crime
le deuxième crime le plus payant et le
plus simple qui se passe le plus
alors moi ça fait quand même 20 ans
alors c'était pas c'est pas pareil et
j'avais même ma mère était dans
l'industrie du sexe pendant longtemps et
on voit que on a banalisé tellement
l'industrie du sexe et puis le de plus
en plus je vois que les personnes
devient vulnérable dans
l'industrie vous vous en êtes sortis oui
vous êtes mariés pour elle votre propre
famille maintenant mais vous a aidée
aussi
les femmes qui sont victimes de cette
traite des personnes de ceux de ses
proxénètes
qu'est ce qui est déterminant pour
constances or justement qu'est ce qui va
aider la jeune femme qui veut s'en
sortir et qui essaie par tous les moyens
quand elle réussit à sauver là qu'est la
première chose qu'il faut dans laquelle
il faut l'aider
c'est un besoin d'hébergement un besoin
d'un retrait de l'industrie du sexe nous
on a ouvert la première maison pour les
victimes d'exploitation sexuelle à
vaudreuil dans la province de québec
on voit pas été beaucoup de maisons pour
lui
une personne de violences conjugales
mais les fans de travail dans
l'industrie du sexe ne veulent pas aller
non cités endroit là parce que c'est et
isolé tu veux pas parler de ta
problématique s'est passé pas la même
réalité
alors c'est important d'avoir plus de
financement plus d'hébergement puis pour
les femmes qui veulent se sortir dans
l'industrie du sexe
quand un loyer à payer tout pas beaucoup
d'éducation comme monsieur la première
dizaine blavou majorité des femmes ont
même pas seconde âges de 6 et en plus le
plus longtemps qu'ils étaient là dedans
c'est le demi isolé par tout et des
points de repère alors avoir un endroit
pour se stabiliser à voir des personnes
qui t'encouragent qui te motive qui
protège aussi déjà et qui est qui et à
une fois que tu penses tu te stabilise
comme vous dites qu est-ce qui quelle
est la prochaine étape pour ces fameux
maintenant on peut rêver encore les
douleurs faire c'était mon père
tellement nos rails puis notre identité
moi je vois souvent après après quelques
semaines même une semaine un téléphone
commence à retrouver espoir a commencé à
réfléchir ok c'est ici qu'est ce que
j'aimerais faire ce que j'aimerais mon
allez on y retourne à l'école allait
trouver un travail prend des formations
travailler sur soi en t elle est allée
travailler les bobos d'enfance les
tourments et les séquelles aussi de ses
activités
de proxénétisme sont peuvent être
longues à guérir beaucoup de
conséquences puisque tu fais plus
confiance à beaucoup de gens aimeraient
que tu as aimé quelqu'un de tout donner
tout est allé dans l'industrie du sexe
pour l'amour de quelqu'un de te rendre
compte que sa personne n'a abusé toi
c'est vraiment difficile à porter alors
t2 d'aider les femmes à se retrouver
qu'elle est si vous aviez une chose à
dire monsieur la première à l'issue des
travaux de cette commission à vos yeux
que les la priorité la priorité la plus
importante la face à cette problématique
c'est sur le financement c'est important
on peut compter sur une main les lundis
aux victimes d'exploitation sexuelle les
ressources sont vraiment limités et
l'ampleur du problème continue à grandir
alors c'est important de financer d'aidé
et perd je mens des programmes vraiment
équipés pour aider ces femmes là et puis
en tant que société aussi c'est d'abord
un changement collectif de la mentalité
envers les personnes dans l'industrie du
sexe parce que la culture populaire nous
donne tellement différents portraits
puis c'est pas la réalité les femmes la
9 sur 10 ne veulent pas travailler dans
l'industrie du sexe alors on fait comme
son soutien le 10 portant qui veut c'est
qu'ils se disent qu'ils aiment leur
travail mais le 90% heures qui sont
laissés à débrouiller par eux-mêmes on a
besoin d'agir en tant que société
financièrement puis de deux minutes à
madame lui bien je vous remercie
beaucoup de nous avoir dit ce que vous
avez fait de ce qui vous est arrivé et
de ce que vous en avez fait aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup